[Music]
we're considering offering young
children technology and mobile devices
or other kinds of screens you know and
they're very very young we have to
consider first of all the stimulation
factor these are brand new people to the
world that are very very sensitive and
highly aware and all of this works to
their great advantage as learners and
absorbers of their environment and life
you know they develop we develop more in
the first three years than in the whole
rest of our life put together so they're
able to learn from a empty room being in
a position where they're you know
ideally freedom to move their bodies so
they're able to move their bodies
they're able to turn their heads we say
start infants on their back for that
reason and they could be fascinated by
dust particles or the corner of the room
or natural light coming in a number of
things and they are you know learning
something from that they're figuring
something out so when we offer
technology it's an onslaught on their
senses basically not so much a phone but
you know a larger screen but even a
mobile device or a small screen it's not
something they're going to be able to
master it's not something they're going
to be able to understand how it all
works imagine an infant who from the RAI
approach we believe wants to be capable
wants to be competent wants to be able
to do things and feel a sense of agency
in the world right away rather than
being passive to something that's sort
of takes over and you're drawn into it
because it's
so much going on there for young
children it can be very over stimulating
and it can discourage them from being
active learners the active learners that
we want them to be that will help them
and throughout life and you know help
them prosper and help them reach their
full full potential make school easier
you know a lot of practical things like
that make them able to retain what they
learn and interested in knowing more so
it's interesting that's the you know
screens they're kind of the extreme on
one end of things babies can understand
so just to give you an example take okay
so then there's their screens where
babies are totally passive and they you
know it's just coming at them and they
they can't really get it then there's
something like a something where you you
know a toy where you push a button and
it makes a sound right so that's pretty
hard for them to understand too I mean
they have some little bit of agency
there that they can figure out well if I
do this it makes this sound but they're
never gonna really understand where the
sound comes from in those early years or
you know in the first year or two and
then there's a rattle so I mean it's a
rattle a terrible thing no but with this
approach we just try to be aware that a
rattle has isn't mystery there's a
mysterious element then there's those
rattles where you can see and through
them to the little thing that's making
the sound a little Bell or whatever and
so that's a little more the child can
feel a little more capable of mastering
that and understanding that so that's a
little more encouraging but then what
about taking a yes one of the things we
use this play objects in our classrooms
where we teach parents and we recommend
this at home too is little stainless
steel cups or bowls so let's just say a
child takes as a block and a little
stainless steel cup and decides to you
know take the block over here make these
sounds now take it off
here and make this sound so now they're
making the sound they're deciding to
make this sound they're creating the the
sound in a sense so which do you think
would be the most fulfilling for a child
which do you think would really
encourage them to be creative to be
learners to analyze to use these
higher-order learning skills
[Music]